jd hasn't cut his fingernails in a long
time he's scared of cutting his nails
for fear of hurting himself
well no i did cut them the other day
they were long whenever i
[ __ ] talked to someone and they saw
how long they were
very difficult to pick my nose and yeah
when i cut my nails i'm always afraid of
getting
too close because it hurts well why are
you cutting him that short
i'll tell you what he is remember when
he tried when
we were out in l.a and we turned him on
to weed and he tried to light the bic
light or he couldn't do it yeah it's not
gonna happen
it's not gonna happen what do you what
is your problem you put the lighter in
one hand and you light
evidently when he handles a nail clipper
i don't know
where his coordination is do that either
yeah he like doesn't know how to work it
really and he has a hard time with the
nail clipper and he ends up cutting his
nails too short
ever heard of a nail file i use i do
that a little bit
but you know it doesn't i can tie my
shoes
and i can wipe my ass i just can't cut
my nails or change my sheets
hey jd what's this i heard i didn't hear
this directly but i heard you had some
interesting thoughts on what happens to
your brain when you die what are you
thinking about there
or yeah it's like you don't know god
but you know like you're worried that
you might actually be awake still when
you're dead or whatever
and that is in never mind
don't don't stop so yeah you don't know
that you're act when you're at when
you're dead
like you could there's the possibility
where your brain could still be
like awake or functioning a little bit
like
you know synapses or whatever are still
going on and
and and and causing things where you're
sort of still
conscious or awake in your head but you
can't move or anything
let me understand this you're afraid
that you'll die
but your brain will still be working
he'll be alive yes yes
uh oh i'm not moving and that is how i
feel whenever
uh i get to sleep uh uh i i forget what
you call it uh
night terrors i don't know it's not
night terrors it's sleep uh know what's
great about talking to you there's
always like mad libs there's a blind
like fill in the blank
that's like uh when you are uh you can
fall asleep and you get ah
night terrorist
[Music]
ashtrays straight square team's gone on
way too long
sure is it nightmares no
hold on i gotta google it it's like
sleep oh sleep paralysis that's what it
is sleep paralysis
i wonder if you're dead can you still
play
madden football you can't tell you can't
tell them what to do
well but what if you have sleep
paralysis and you can't work the
controls
you